[Music]
the founder of the company said her
carpets should be as music she was the
composer and the weavers were the
musicians and you when you walk on the
carpet you listen to the music
[Music]
in the metamours studio we're doing
useful art textile metamours she was an
artist and she was so fascinated over
the oriental carpets that she saw 100
years ago
we are still producing her carpets and
we have more than almost thousand
different designs it's an honor to get
to know her through her work her design
her sketches when we have a client put
an order of a special carpet here the
weavers start lining up the threads for
the war the warp is the backbone it's
the spine of the carpet it should bear
the carpet of all its life that's almost
always and flax or linen and we are
winding them up going round around and
it's really important so that all
threads are exactly the same length and
we are taking them down from the
spinning wheel and then you invite your
colleagues to come to a boom Ning's
party it's when you set the warp in the
Loom we thread them through steel eyes
so it's going to be really tight and
it's going to be really even we are many
and we're talking and laughing and we
know it's a start for new projects so
it's really a good day when we are doing
booming
we have about eight tons of John in 16
1700 different colors and if we're
missing something we need to dye it and
then we have white wool coming from
Sweden or Norway and it needs to be
really strong a good rule and not the
sweater rule and not soft and nice
reduce the synthetic reactive colors we
have three pigment colors red and blue
and yellow and all these three colors
you do everything with if you are really
used to work with colors you can see
maybe twice or three times as much as a
normal people
[Music]
matter most fearsome lived her last 22
years and coastline here in Boston but
she grew up where there were a lot of
trees and flowers carpet was not common
in Sweden before that we had sand and
plants on the floor that we were forming
in Nice patterns so it's really the
nature that has got inspiration to the
different carpets what artists are not
inspired by nature and what human being
is not inspired by nature we get all the
John's ready and we wind it up into
small balls in right combinations of
colors and threads we always prepare
that before we start doing the flat wave
carpet it's called a relic on a Swedish
different techniques can give you
different solutions but in the relic on
the wall is going between the wall it's
really strong and it's reversible
and so it's really old technique in the
very cold countries you have different
kind of working instructions for
different carpets and it's built up by
small squares it's really important for
us to pass on the knowledge from
generation to generation and we do that
by sitting - and - in the news it might
take a year to do the carpet suceed
beside the same weaver they are today in
and of course you know everything about
each other so you could rest together
without the person it's like walking in
silence you could work in silence beside
each other
eventually when you are finished with
your carpet novels the cast down and
you're allowed to see the whole carpet
because you have stored it during the
process of weaving it's like waiting me
for a baby coming you know that it is
there you feel it you can see it you
have been through everything but you
don't know exactly what will come out
and after that they carpet need to rest
and we do some flattening we just nail
it to the floor and putting a little bit
of water and then we put wooden plates
on so it's going to stay there for four
or five days and then it's ready to be
rolled and packed and then shipped to
the owner
[Music]
I've been talking to so many clients and
they could see their whole life in the
carpet they could see the children
growing up the parties the divorces the
quarrels the happiness the sadness
so we focusing the whole life to one
room to one spot to one carpet it's
really a joy and pressure to make
something that lasts
you